[Music]
question.
Don't worry.
[Music]
question.
talk.
Welcome, welcome to the table. Uh my
name is Cat. My pronouns are she, her.
We're so glad to have you this evening.
Thank you for being with us. Even if
this is your first time or if this is
your first time in a long time, we're
glad that you're here.
If you're anxious about being in a
church setting, we have a a little
accessibility bucket that's got fidget
spinners and coloring sheets and
headphones and things. If you need them,
you can pick them up on your way in and
drop them off on your way out.
And if you would like to learn more
about the table,
the community that we have here, uh we
are offering a welcome to the table
class. Um and you can scan the QR code
um on the website to yeah there um to
get more information about that.
A great a great way to just be
introduced this community.
These candles
are a sign
of the presence of Christ among us.
Fully divine and fully human.
Now we exit
the kingdom of noise,
hurry, productivity.
And now we enter the kingdom of silence.
stillness
and grace.
Now we enter sacred space,
a space for prayer, worship and
adoration,
a space to encounter Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you,
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
All right, let's stand together.
Psalm 9 says, "I'll praise you, oh Lord,
with all my heart. I'll tell of all your
wonders. I'll be glad and rejoice in
you. I'll sing praise to your name."
So that's what we've gathered here to do
is lift him up. remember that he is a
good God and he is with us and for us.
So let's sing from that posture tonight
and uh lift up our hearts.
[Music]
Mercy
rising with the rising of the sun.
[Music]
Goodness
rushing and filling up my lungs.
[Music]
Your faithfulness
is here and now.
The evidence
is all around.
I bless your name. I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Oh my soul. Come on and praise the Lord.
Sing oh my soul. Oh
my soul
praise
the Lord.
Oh
my soul.
Today is a day for singing.
A new song
is well enough from deep inside of me.
And there is new life.
Hallelujah. I have been redeemed. I have
been redeemed.
I bless your name.
I give you the rest.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord.
Today is the day for singing.
Sing oh my soul. Oh
my soul.
Praise
the Lord.
>> Oh
my soul,
today is a day for singing.
Today,
>> Can you guys clap with me?
Let's sing from the valley.
From the valley to the mountain, theert
to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you
from the morning to the evening. As long
as I am breathing,
a day for singing.
Now let's sing aloud. From the valley to
the mountain, the desert to the
fountains.
Oh, I will praise you.
From the morning to the evening, as long
as I can brea. Today is a day for
singing. One more time. Today.
Today is a day for singing.
I bless your name.
I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord.
Today is a day for singing. Sing. Oh my
soul.
Oh
my soul.
Praise
the Lord.
Oh my soul. Oh
my soul.
>> Today is a day for singing.
>> From the valley to the mountain, the
desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you.
From
the morning to the evening
I am breathing.
>> Today is a day for singing. Today
is a day for singing.
Today is a day for singing.
>> All right. If you are sixth grade or
under,
you can meet up over here with these
kiddos at this door and your teachers
will meet you and take you to your
classrooms.
So glad you guys are here.
[Music]
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people.
[Music]
So you guys be sure to um speak out and
share the things that are on your heart
in this space.
Follow along um the parts in red on the
screen with us.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you
for the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender, sexuality, race, or other
perceived difference. We pray to you
for those experiencing loss, loneliness,
and disconnection. And for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray to you. Lord, we know
that you love us and that you hear us.
So we lift these names and situations up
to you.
[Music]
Jesus,
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud, and for those that we
have kept in our hearts. We pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen.
[Music]
Come and tear down the walls I built up.
Every wall I built up. Every wall I
built up.
You deserve every
[Music]
tear down the walls I've built up. Every
wall I've built up. Every wall I've
built up.
You deserve every piece of my heart.
Every piece of my heart. Every piece of
my heart. And Lord,
I am trusting that you are faithful
father. and all that you have it is
good.
You're a genous giver with loves like no
other. Won't you come and break through
to me over and over and over again? I am
bringing my heart to you with open
hands.
Closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
[Music]
Come and tear down the walls I built up.
Every wall I'm built up. Every wall I'm
built up.
You deserve every piece of my heart.
Every piece of my heart, every piece of
my heart. And Lord,
I am trusting that you are a faithful
father. and all that you have in his
good.
You're a generous giver with loves like
no other. Won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again? I am bringing my heart to you
with open hands.
Closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
Over and over and over again. I am
bringing my heart to you with open
hands.
Closer and closer. You join me in as the
depths of my heart lay before you again.
Come and tear down the walls I built up.
Every wall I build up. Every wall I
build up. Cuz you deserve every piece of
my heart. Every piece of my heart. Every
piece of my heart,
[Music]
you're deserving.
You're deserving.
[Music]
Come and tear down the walls I've built
up. Every wall I've built up, every wall
I've built up.
You deserve every piece of my heart.
Every piece of my heart. Every piece of
my heart.
[Music]
Jeremiah 29.
This is what the Lord says.
When 70 years are completed for Babylon,
I will come to you and fulfill my
gracious promise to bring you back to
this place. For I know the plans I have
for you, declares the Lord. Plans to
prosper you and not to harm you.
Plans to give you a hope and a future.
Then you will call upon me and come and
pray to me and I will listen to you.
You will seek me and find me when you
seek me with all your heart and I will
be found by you.
[Music]
Lord, I come.
I confess.
Bowing here.
I find my rest.
And without you,
I fall apart.
You're the one
that guides my heart.
[Music]
Lord, I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every
hour I need
you. My one
defense,
my rightousness.
Oh God, how I need
you.
[Music]
Where sin runs deep,
your grace is more,
where grace is found
is where you are.
And where you are,
Lord, I am free.
Holy
is Christ in me.
And where you are,
Lord, I am free.
Holy
is Christ in me.
Lord, I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every
hour I need
you.
My one defense,
my rightousness.
Oh God, how I need you.
>> So teach my song to bless you.
When temptation comes my way.
[Music]
>> And when I cannot stand, I'll fall on
you.
>> Jesus, you're my hope and stay.
Hey
Lord, I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every
hour I need
you.
My one defense,
my rightousness.
[Music]
Oh God, how I need you.
>> Oh God, how I need
you.
[Music]
>> Oh God, how I need you.
Oh God, how I need you.
[Music]
God, would you make us aware of our need
where we overcrowd our schedules
and we fill our mental feed with all the
scrolling and the activities and the
responsibil Please
[Music]
God, would you help us to recognize
our own brokenness?
Would
[Music]
you help us to see the areas where we
need to stop
and slow down
and reach out
[Music]
the areas where we need
we need your love.
We need your presence, your peace of
mind.
[Music]
We need your forgiveness,
God. We need you.
Would you set our course?
Would you be our guide?
Would we have hearts and ears that are
listening for your voice?
[Music]
God, lead us towards your love in all
things
in Jesus name. Amen.
Would you guys turn to the person beside
you and say, "The peace of Christ be
with you." And then you may be seated.
[Music]
Grace in peace.
My name is Brett. For those who have
forgotten after my month away, it's um
it's really good to good to be back. Uh
I was I was gone. For those who don't
know, I was gone all of July and uh and
I was back last Sunday, but it was like
a little bit different. We had Sunday
Unbound over there in the gym and you
know, not not quite the same. So, um
yeah, it's really really good to to be
back here u with with all of you and uh
a huge thank you to those who stepped in
while I was out. I know we had folks
speaking and uh people just picking up
the slack for because it was not only
me, it was me, it was um Mindy who's
leading worship, it was uh my wife
Maggie uh in kids ministry and just all
over the place people were stepping up
to give us this, you know, this that
time I should say. And yeah, it was
really special. So I am uh I'm feeling
re-energized.
I played a lot of golf, not even lying.
And it was good. mostly practice range
because golf's expensive. So, mostly
driving range, but a few times I got to
actually play the course and it was
yeah, just really restorative. Read lots
of books and uh yeah, feeling feeling
excited to to be back with you all. So,
um let's see. Next week, we're going to
be kicking off a new series titled
Cultivating Calm. Uh but this week, I
want to do kind of a little a little
one-off message before we we get going
with that um that new one. And so the
title of my message uh this week is the
emotional shake. And our passage is the
very words of Christ from the gospel of
Matthew chapter 6 verses 16-18
uh which reads when you fast Jesus says
do not look somber as the hypocrites do
for they disfigure their faces to show
others they are fasting. Truly I tell
you they have received their reward in
full. But instead, when you fast, put
oil on your head, wash your face, so
that it will not be obvious to others
that you are fasting, but only to your
father who is unseen, and your father
who sees what is done in secret will
reward you. So Jesus opens here with uh
the phrase, when you fast,
uh notice it's not if you fast, but
when. And we might wonder like why why
is he assuming this? Well, to understand
that you need to know Jesus culture,
right? It's a very different one than
our own. He's this is a few thousand
years ago Jewish culture and there, you
know, seasons of religious feasting and
fasting. It was like the norm, you know.
So, I think that's why Jesus is if you
were speaking the 21st century, I think
it had to be really a different tone,
you know, not just assuming everyone's
fasting all, you know. Um, so instead,
he kind of goes on to kind of clarify
the types of, you know, fasts he he
wants. Now, like I mentioned, that's,
you know, that's just not our culture.
Uh, fasting, that is, for those
unfamiliar, kind of giving something up,
um, usually in this context, food, uh,
you know, for some period of time,
that's that's just not something we, you
know, do a lot. And I mean, it's almost
like, yeah, I think it really hits us in
a weird way, honestly. like almost like
if you've heard that phrase about uh
beer is proof God wants us or loves us
and wants us to be happy. You all heard
this phrase. I think it's like said
Benjamin Franklin said this though I
think that's be I don't really know. Um
but so my kind of reversal that is like
well then if that's true fasting is like
the obvious or it's the the opposite I
should say like if actually fasting
would be proof God hates us and wants us
to be miserable you know and I think
that's kind of the modern mindset of
fasting like it just strikes us as
utterly bizarre you know just like what
a fasting like why why would you hate
yourself why would you hurt yourself why
would you do something that is going to
like cause you some suffering or what?
It just it makes and then somehow this
pleases God. God's like, "Yeah, that's
what I'm talking about. Are you
miserable?" Perfect. You know, uh it
just Yeah, the whole thing strikes us, I
think, as kind of just a strange thing.
So,
now I think it does also need to be
named like like I kind of alluded to.
Jesus here is my guess is he is thinking
of food specifically as I've mentioned
in previous messages. I think right
before Lent, I mentioned this. that's
the season, you know, fasting that leads
up to um Easter and all that. Uh
I I think that's somewhat problematic
today because of our relationship to
food. We have this weird scientific
kind of you know a thing where you have
people who are like engineering food to
be like maximally delicious in every
way. you know, I mean, just maxing out
the fat, sugar, salt. And so that's just
it's very easy to get into this
unhealthy relationship with food where
it's this kind of weird like binge purge
thing. You know what I mean? Like a kind
of like, oh my gosh, okay. No, no, no. I
should I got to stop that. It's a new
day. I'm never touching that stuff
again. I last like three days. It's
like, okay, no, that is I'm done with
that. You know, and you and you can see
where that's like a short step. You
combine that with some kind of social
media scenes, certain images of people
and idealized, you know, body image
stuff like you just it's just a whole
cocktail of like this is just a recipe
for eating disorders all over the place.
Right? So because of that uh I'm if
you've had any history with with kind of
eating disorders, I do not suggest at
all you even consider fasting food. That
needs to be off the table. Let's just um
and honestly it's it's quite unnecessary
because the truth is we can fast
anything that we aren't utterly
indifferent to. You know, I mean
obviously if you're just like I don't
care about that thing. I'll fast that.
Okay. Well, that's not really going to
work. But if there's something you're
like, "Oh, I really enjoy that or I love
that or I you know, oh that's that's
perfect. That that that can um totally
totally work." So kind of throughout
this message, you know, when Jesus
talked about fasting here, I want you to
kind of broaden your horizon a little
bit to include, you know, things other
than food. So, okay, coming back to
verse 16. Jesus said, "When you fast, do
not look somber as the hypocrites do,
for they disfigure their faces to show
others they are fasting. Truly, I tell
you, they receive their reward in full."
So, this brings us to kind of a key
question, you know, of well, okay, so
why fast? And here you can see one very
poor answer kind of emerging. And this
is the trap that the the Pharisees, the
kind of religious folks of that day
started to fall into. Uh which is
basically, you know, fasting as like a
flex, you know, fa fasting as kind of
like, oh, I'm pretty spiritual, you
know. Uh this is really problematic,
though. So I mean I've got to say like
I can relate to this in the sense of you
know when when I'm doing a hard thing
whether fasting or otherwise there is
nothing like being noticed. You know
what I mean? Have you had this
experience where it's just like you're
doing this thing and you're kind of like
no no one needs to see but then if
someone does like hey look at you you
know you're like oh I mean just even if
you kind of play it cool on the outside
you know on the inside it's just like
yes I am I am doing a hard thing. Thank
you for noticing. And you can see where
with fasting like this very quickly
becomes like a huge problem. Um because
as we'll get into fasting is really
trying to kind of diminish the ego. But
you can see where this ends up
completely going around it and now it's
like inflating you know the ego. I had
uh the last church I served at was um at
least for the town it was in Wy and for
that town it was you know a largeish
church not like Texas mega church large
you know 30,000 men not that you know
but it was still it was a fairly larger
church so because of that it wasn't it
was not unusual that um people you know
when I was around town people would like
I would just see people from the church
like you know consistently and one of
the experiences I had or not one but
another way this played out was uh I
would go on like runs out around WY in
the morning and people would see me from
the church and sometimes if it was like
on a little, you know, road and like a
neighborhood and they pull over, they'd
be like, "Hey, Brett." And I was like,
"Hey." And they're like, "I didn't know
you ran." And I'm like, "Yeah, I'm a bit
of a runner, you know. I'm not a hero.
Just a normal guy doing extraordinary
things, you know." Uh, but it was it
really, even though I tried to not let
it impact me, the truth is it did. I was
kind like, "Yeah, I am. I'm running. I'm
out here." Oh, yeah. Miles even, you
know, or I didn't say that, but I was
thinking that. And, you know, just
that's the thing. It just kind of
touches something in us of when we're,
you know, we get noticed doing a hard
thing or just our ego just soaks it up
like a like a little sponge. And and you
can see where this becomes a problem,
right? something where we have a
different intention for it, but all of a
sudden this kind of side benefit of
people noticing before we realize it,
whether fasting or otherwise becomes
like the prime thing. Have you had this
experience where it didn't start off
trying to do it for people's approval or
then noticing or you know, but all of a
sudden it became about that. And that's
I think what Jesus is um kind of getting
at here, right? The folks he's
describing uh fell into this trap. And
again, keep in mind, right, the the
context where this was a culture, like I
mentioned that, you know, was a much
more spiritually minded culture than we
live in. So, it was this time and place
where personal holiness and piety and
fasting like, you know, this was
venerated. This was like, whoa, you're
part of the the spiritual elite, you
know, as opposed to just maybe today it
would be like, that's weird. Why are you
doing that? You know, back then it was
like a really, you know, cool thing. And
so where folks were taking it, he
mentions they're disfigure their faces.
I mean, I don't think it was like, "Hey,
they're cutting, you know, I think it's
more like um probably using some makeup,
maybe like increasing the bags under the
eyes." He mentions oil on the hair,
which was sort of like doing your hair.
And so maybe the hair was unkempt.
They're trying to get that that look
going, you know, kind of that um that
kind of man oh man, am I ever exhausted
from my spiritual pursuits look going
and where people are like, "Let me
guess. You're fasting." And you're like,
"Oh, yes, perhaps." You know, and uh so
this is what was going on. And of
course, it's it's shallow, full of
spiritual egoism. And so, rightly,
Jesus, you know, pushes back. Verse 17,
but when you fast, I want you to do
that. When you fast, I want you to put
oil on your head. Right? In other words,
do your hair. I want you to wash your
face. So, it will not be obvious to
others you are fasting, but only to your
father who's unseen and your father who
sees what is done in secret. And we come
to this interesting phrase, will reward
you.
will reward you. I've been pondering
that the father, in other words, God
will reward you. Uh I think where our
minds can go with this is actually
another kind of unhelpful
path with fasting where we turn God into
like the I don't know if anyone says
this anymore, but like the sugar daddy
in the sky, you know, the the kind of
like Yes. Okay. So, it's it becomes this
sort of transactional relationship, you
know, like Okay. Okay. Okay, I will
fast. I will be miserable. Slight at
least slightly miserable, but I'm doing
it right. So, I because I want XYZ
outcome from you. So, we've got a little
bargain going here, God, and you
promised to hold up, you know, your side
of it because you said, I mean, if if I
suffered enough, you would reward me as
Matthew chapter 6 verse 18 says.
So kind of to to summarize this is the
other problem with fasting. So to kind
of name these two. So bad motivations
for fasting. Number one to impress
others with my spiritual depth and
commitment. This is this is a problem.
And number two as we just named to
manipulate God into doing what I want
i.e. demanding rewards. Okay. So getting
these out of the way. These are like
let's let's not fast for these these
reasons. Okay. So if not these well then
what you know or or why why I mean what
does verse 18 what is it getting at with
this okay will reward you well part of
the genius of fasting is
it's not so much I think that God like
sees your suffering and your hunger and
says you know oh okay you've really
earned this and so I'm going to come
through for you in some way. I I think
instead we could say that fasting it's
uh it's like a vaccine.
It's like a vaccine for suffering
um and even for sin, which we'll get
into in a second. So like in essence, if
you think of what a vaccine does, right?
It introduces just a little bit of the
virus
that your body then learns to fight off.
And in this way you kind of get your
immune system gets like stronger. And I
think that's sort of a perfect picture
and metaphor for what fasting does
because like similarly when I fast what
am I doing? I'm like voluntarily
entering into
at least a little bit of suffering. you
know, I'm I'm introducing some
discomfort, some a little bit of even
kind of some pain, you know, into my
life in in some way. It's stirring it's
going to stir up some negative or
uncomfortable feelings.
And this in turn
reveals to me how I react
and where I still need to grow. In other
words, fasting, I think, can encourage
awareness and growth. Now, I also said
it's an antidote kind of to to sin or
vaccine against sin because uh you know,
when am I most likely to do things that
harm myself and others, which I think is
a decent definition of sin.
When when is that? Well, it's when I am
in a kind of emotionally
disregulated,
dysfunctional state, right? In other
words, we might say sin is kind of often
a stupid solution to a very real
emotional problem.
The uh the language I've liked for this
recently is from Dr. Julia Dangji. She's
she's a neurossychologist and she calls
it the emotional shake in our life. An
emotional shake is the feeling that
accompanies a kind of disregulated
nervous system. So like sometimes an
example of this is it results in like
literal shaking. For example, if you
have to like do some public speaking or
something and you might be find yourself
right your hands like literally
trembling or even before like a hard
conversation with someone and you might
be a little little trembly. Uh but she
really means it. I mean it can include
that but really it's a bit more of like
a metaphor for like in the internal
state we find ourselves basically that
kind of uh raw edgy kind of nerve
jangling
you know restlessness or craving I mean
I'm kind of throwing out a lot of words
here hoping to connect with something in
you I mean can you kind of relate to you
know some of this this feeling this is
uh basically just kind of negative
emotional energy, right? And this can
happen when someone um humiliates you or
criticizes you uh in a moment where you
feel like a failure, when you feel
overwhelmed.
It can be the the emotional shake of
addiction, right? Whether it's a kind of
a craving for drugs or alcohol or
pornography or, you know, just whatever
you're kind of craving craving, needing.
And it can be also just the shake of
anxiety and fear. In other words, we
have kind of like a thousand different
emotions uh and kind of challenging
emotions and feelings, but often
manifests in our nervous system in a
very kind of consistent similar way. In
essence, we get a kind of emotion. We
have the emotional shake
and in short
we don't like it.
You know, it's like I just Yeah, that
feeling. I freaking hate that. I hate
that. I'll do anything to get out of
that.
Right. And this is why um I say this is
where like suffering and sin and pain,
you know, often leads us into like
really stupid things because we'll kind
of we're looking for anything to uh rid
ourselves or ease kind of the the
emotional shake in the moment. And and
so in fact, we often spend our whole
lives honestly kind of trying to avoid
the people, the situations, the
experiences that cause the shake.
But here's here's the question I want to
ask. What if we had a different response
to that feeling? What if actually that
emotional shake was an invitation
spirit from the Holy Spirit to grow? The
meditation teacher Pimachan put it this
way that each day we're given many
opportunities to open up or shut down.
Most of us do not take these situations
as teachings. We automatically hate
them. We run like crazy. We use all
kinds of ways to escape. In fact, all
addictions stem from this moment when we
meet our edge.
We just can't stand it.
So,
bringing this back to fasting, when I am
going to fast,
what am I doing?
I am intentionally
inviting the shake.
You see it? You see where you when you
take that step, right? You're doing the
thing and you know like, oh man, this is
going to do that thing to me, that thing
that I mostly try to spend my life uh
avoiding.
And I'm going to invite a little bit of
that that discomfort, that edgginess,
that pain. But rather than
running like crazy as children says, I'm
going to do my best to face it, to relax
into it, and to find myself and thus God
in the midst of it.
Uh back in December, I went on a uh
three-day, three night little silence
retreat with the with the Jesuits. They
have a place out in Lewisville and
they're on Lake Lewisville. And uh the
way they kind of structure it is you
have like the opening meal and the
closing meal. So opening meal kind of
Thursday afternoon, the closing meal
Sunday afternoon, you can speak to
people then. Uh but then like all that
time, you know, in between
no talking, you know, just just just
quiet. And uh now I'm an introvert, you
know, so honestly I found the meals
where I would just I mean it was a
little bit awkward. It is a little
strange to like sit across from someone
and eat and say absolutely nothing to
them. A little bit of a strange
experience, but as an introvert kind of
kind of liked it better than speaking to
them. I like I don't really want to talk
to you, you know. Um, so
that for was, you know, kind of good.
But I uh
I I kind of knew though I knew myself
and I knew that to some degree I'm kind
of okay, you know, with like silence.
And uh I also knew though my last
resort, like my last little thing that
keeps me from the edge, that keeps uh my
emotional shake at bay. Um I knew that
it is books like in the end I knew even
if I fast like all the things you know I
mean I let go of podcasts and I let go
of Netflix and reading internet articles
or even hanging out or talking with
people. I knew if I give all that up I
always have a book on hand to distract
myself.
And so I decided going into that silence
retreat, I would bring no books.
It was, y'all, I'm not going to lie, it
was uh the first day was fine and then
that silence started setting in, you
know, and I just didn't have like uh I
don't know. I just didn't have an
outlet, you know what I mean? just
didn't and honestly it was I don't know
if you'all remember back in December it
was like pre Christmas and there was
this weekend where it just rained it
just rained and rained and rained and
just days and that was that was the
weekend I was gone and so it wasn't even
like oh going to go outside and just
like enjoy nature nope I was pretty much
just in my room and uh
slowly but surely these kind of feelings
of boredom feelings of like a certain
loneliness you know kind of set in and
this is normally when I'd reach for
what? My book, preferably books plural,
you know, I just kind of like how if I
find one boring and I jump to the next
one, you know what I mean? It just And
uh I I had, you know, none of this. And
uh I was I was like a drinker in rehab.
You know, I needed my distraction to put
it a little bit melodramatically, but um
I needed my distraction, but it was
gone. All my familiar exits taken away.
And uh all I could do I just sat down in
my little chair in my room, closed my
eyes, and just
just did my best did my best to
relax into those feelings, kind of ride,
you know, we got to kind of ride it out.
And uh and sure enough, you know, kind
of strangely like although it was, you
know, painful, but like you know, by
like later day two, I was I don't know,
I was like relaxing into it. And uh you
know, you kind of find when you fast in
these ways that actually your worst case
scenario doesn't happen. You know,
you're like, I'm going to die without
that. I don't know. It's like weird. Our
brains get so dramatic of like, I can't
possibly live. You know what I mean? I
need you get that feeling it's like no
anything to avoid the fe you know and we
get very dramatic about it and actually
if you'll kind of like write it out it's
like oh actually it was okay you know
the feeling subsides for a while maybe
an hour maybe a day and uh and then it
kind of rolls back and then you have to
like write it out you know again what I
found was by facing these feelings by
sitting with them rather than running
from them uh becomes a really
unbelievably powerful experience
and I think this is the first step
towards
the growth um that I was naming earlier.
I think this learning to embrace
reality,
the present moment as people talk about
learning to be here and be okay with
what is. It's like I mean all the
spiritual masters say like this is a key
aspect of learning to live in the
presence of God. like as long as we're
running from here now,
we're not going to um
find seek and find God. As Mindy was
reading um earlier in that in that
passage, you see, we might say that
fasting reveals the addict in all of us,
the ways that we use and abuse people
and things to avoid our pain,
to avoid our our shake. In this sense,
fasting really is I would think of this
more like um it's like training for
life. You know, whenever we fast, it's
easy to get kind of locked in on like
the I don't know the intensity of the
the thing or the time frame or the you
know, whatever I'm oh, I'm going to fast
this lint. I'm going to give up, you
know, whatever the thing is or uh or I'm
going to go on this meditation retreat
or silence retreat. going to it's going
to be three days or you know we get kind
of locked in on like that as though it's
about that you know when really the
truth is like well yes but the idea is
really that's a launching pad like in
essence that's a little moment that is
teaching you to face the shake in the
rest of your life right that's the point
it's not so much about lent or the
retreat or the moment you know what I
mean like it is but it isn't it's that's
the that's the launching pad to so much
more. Which is also why I I think in
this sense fasting is unbelievably
underrated. Like we're really missing a
lot by avoiding I mean in ways we're
missing everything by uh by avoiding it.
So to kind of put this into a framework
for life um we might call these the four
Rs. Like if you're wondering how do I do
this like in my life here now? Because
honestly it's not even like I said it
doesn't have to be like and now I'm
committing to fast such and such for a
week you know really you can approach a
lot of life like this because we're
often facing these feelings. So uh I got
these four Rs from uh Pimma who I quoted
earlier. Uh so first recognize the urge
kind of recognize the moment that that
emotional shake that feeling you know in
your kind of that urge that impulse to
like I got to do the thing or I got you
know I got to avoid this or I got
whatever recognize it. Second, refrain
from reacting
in your usual ways, right? The the usual
activity or whatever. Third, relax into
the fe. It's like me in the little room
there at the retreat. Just
kind of relax into it. Fourth, resolve
to continue.
This is really how fasting becomes a
lifestyle. And I think to this point I
think or I hope you can see
the rewards like Jesus mentioned that
might come from this. I mean just
imagine the freedom that can begin to
happen in your life when you're not
bullied
by these feelings so much when you're
not freaking out
about that urge, that impulse, that
desire, you know, whatever the thing is.
learning to kind of relax into all of
that. I think this is really a key
aspect of how we grow into Christ
likeness and a key part of the path of
disciplehip. So, I'll close with this uh
this quote from David uh Dan Fiser. He
says this, "Want a sugary treat? Sit
with it. Be with it. Move through it.
Want to turn on the TV, social media,
Netflix? Sit with it. Be with it. Move
through it. You want to swipe left,
swipe right, look for Mr. or Mrs. Right,
sit with it, be with it, move through
it. We have a thousand ways to escape,
sedate, distract, stimulate, numb, and
not face ourselves,
not face our loneliness, not face the
pain of the unloved self. And this is
the loop of life. And so we keep seeking
and searching, trying, wanting,
pleasing, soothing, distracting,
sedating, escaping
constantly,
never being with self.
But loneliness is calling you home.
That's where the peace is.
In the name of the Father, Son, Holy
Spirit.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it. He said, "Take
and eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." He held up a cup of wine. He
said, "Take this and drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me."
So as we come forward tonight, I hope
you can do it in that kind of heart
posture to connect with uh Christ in
this way. So we'll um do communion just
in our kind of usual way. We'll form a
line here in the middle and just start
kind of going rowby row, working our way
back. Um we practiced an open table, so
everyone is welcome to participate if
you'd like to. Having said that, there's
also no pressure. If you'd rather not
participate, that's okay. You don't have
to. Uh you should know the red is wine,
the white is grape juice. And and then
finally, you can just partake whenever,
however you'd like. Some people take
immediately, some people like to come
and kneel at the front. Just do that
however you'd like.
So this is the table, not of the church,
but of the Lord. It's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you feel like you
failed.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
If you guys want to stand up with us for
this last song, we're going to sing Lord
I Need You Again. Um,
one of the things that
we were kind of making fun of the bridge
earlier in practice, but actually the
words to the bridge have been meaningful
to me because um, that first line is
teach my song to rise to you when
temptation comes my way. And
recently, I've found a lot of times when
I'm in my car by myself on my way to
work or whatever and I have a bunch of
the emotional um
overload going on from the different
things, you know, that we all carry with
us and we're always processing and it's
so easy to find like some kind of, you
know, escape in those moments like we
were talking about. But lately, I've
just been returning to like a chorus
that's encouraging. Um, something that
brings me back. Sometimes it's that
chorus, if you might know the Lauren
Dagel song, that's everything's going to
be okay. And I'll just sing that chorus
over myself and just ask God to meet me
in that moment. And it's just what this
song is saying. It's just teaching us
instead of going to the escape, the easy
out to just sit in that emotion and
receive from God and see what he has to
say. Listening to his heart, believing
that it's going to be okay. He's with
me. I'm loved. We're taken care of. The
sun will continue to rise.
We will continue to grow even through
our pain. So let's sing this song
together. Just recognizing our need and
inviting Christ into that place
[Music]
where sin runs deep.
Your grace is more
where grace is found.
Is where you are.
where you are
Lord I am free
holyness
is Christ to me
and where you are
Lord I am free
holyness
is Christ in me.
Oh
Lord, I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every
hour I need
you, my one defense,
my rightousness.
Oh God, how I need you.
>> So teach my song to rise to you
[Music]
>> when temptation comes my way.
>> When I cannot stand up on you.
Jesus, you're my hope and stay.
>> Jesus, you're my hope and stay.
>> Lord, I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every
hour I need
you. My one defense,
my rightousness.
[Music]
Oh God, how I need you,
>> Lord. I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every hour I need
My one defense,
my rightousness.
Oh God, how I need
you.
>> Oh God, how I need
[Music]
Thank you guys for joining us this
evening.
If you are new,
we would love for you to fill out a card
at the table or go scan the QR code. Uh
you can find out some information about
the table and and if we have any if you
have any questions then we'll be able to
reach out to you and answer those.
Um generosity is a real key aspect of
adoration in the life of worship.
If you would like to give financially,
you can scan the QR code and do that.
If you call the table home and do not
serve on a ministry team and would be
interested in that, we have several
wonderful ones. Um, you can also
scan the QR code and and go to the table
at tx.org.
I think I did that right. Uh, I never
know the website. Anyway, at the tablet
tx.org. That right. And you can find a
ministry team that works for you.
There's the the host team, the welcome
and and host committee that sets up. I
call them the little elves that you
don't see.
>> Um and then they strike it. We have our
wonderful um AV team and our wonderful
praise team and we have our wonderful
kids ministry. So if you're interested
um you have a a gift, please reach out.
We'd love to have you.
Also, if you do not have a meetup, we
have several meetups available. Lots of
different directions and locations at
houses on different times of the week so
you can find one that that works for
you. Um,
now I'm going to send you out
with this blessing.
You can hold your hand out or hands out
in a posture to receive or you can just
open your hearts these words.
You are a child of God.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and this
is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead, which
is yet to be determined, highs and lows,
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved, that you are worthy, and that you
are accepted
just as you are.
and go
filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend those same gifts of
grace
and unconditional love to all of those
that you meet and come in contact with.
Be blessed.
Have a good week. And we hope to see you
back again next Sunday.
Good night.
[Music]
Lord, I need you. Oh, I need
you.
Every
hour I need
you. My one defense,
my rightousness.
Oh God, how I need
you.
Oh God, how I need you.
[Music]